this is such a beloved show at ET
everybody just loves one day at a time
and when we heard that you guys were
coming back for season four on pop can
you believe it I mean can you I mean it
really pays to put out
[Music]
I am so I want to know where were you
and how did you react when you heard
that one day at a time was coming back
officially for season four I was
planting tomato seeds for reals yeah for
real it's one of the few things I don't
have real hobbies that's a hobby that's
one of the things that I just love to do
I love to garden and so unlike my
character Lydia but I answered the phone
and I was so happy
who called you I was really it was my
agent oh wow was the agent and he said
you're on again you know a lot of times
when shows unfortunately get cancelled
but then they find a second life a lot
of the actors have already previously
committed to new things and they're
unavailable how does it feel to know
you're back again with the entire
Alvarez family we are delirious
we are deliriously happy and what's
interesting is that because now we have
a shorter show in terms of minutes 9 so
how are you doing with that with
commercials and all that I don't know
how to say this but the show has gotten
even better its height it to be tight
and punchy because we don't have as much
time as we used to and I remember
thinking oh this is not gonna be easy
this is not good
it's a joy it just barrels through those
22 I think it's 22 minutes something
like that and there's comedy fire no no
more than that yes more than that it's
funnier we have some new writers not
that the bat the old ones were bad but
with some new young writers because
really our writers room is like a UN of
everything yeah cluding sexuality gender
well that's how we see such brilliant
writing on the show is that it's
reflected in these people's real lives
exactly and I mean so far this is our
third episode right now they were
shooting and you've never seen a cast
cracking up so much during the scenes
and other people's renditions of their
lines
it's such
yeah I mean it's just it seems like the
purest joy to be a part of this show in
this particular episode well not giving
anything away
Lydia and Penelope her daughter have
knocked down drag about Justyna and I
adore those scenes because we both get
so lucky now and we a bash on it and
what are you talking about Jordan Gracie
you know and she goes and we just turn
into these verrano's but funny funny
virag OHS and there is a delicious scene
in the middle of this where we just get
furious at each other because we were
both convinced that we are right yes of
course always especially this Carrie oh
you're never wrong Lydia's Lorena de la
casa mi didn't wound Oh see see there's
no the queen of the world yes we'll
listen I want to know what's going on
with Lydia's love life this season this
season tell me you know I really don't
know yet what are you hoping for do you
want the Lydia dr. B relationship or are
you not so much a fan well no I know I
am you like it I love him yeah I love
Steven God he's funny
and he has a wonderful juicy part in the
episode number 2 which is delicious and
delightful and he's got a terrific part
in this episode number 3 which engages
Lydia in in a very very funny way so oh
yes I love him in my life I think it's
hilarious what I can't wait for cuz I
don't know yet is what happened in Cuba
correct which is we're all West which is
where we all left and I don't know yet I
have no idea so I can't wait I want to
know what is on Rita Marino's beau
Kahless more of the same listen I'm I'm
88 unbelievable I mean when West Side
Story comes out next year in December
I'll be 80 this year all right this year
that's right yeah I'll be 89 so you know
my documentary is going to come out I
think sometime this spring or summer
which is produced by Norman Lear and
lin-manuel Miranda ah I mean well this
is 88 you said
saying it doesn't surprise me because
you're aware so you could see all this
we're all very proud of you
um I do want to know are you as excited
about the idea of lin-manuel guest
starring on the show can you look in the
camera and ask him to come on the show
then man we'll get off your culito
come on man we're not and you really
should be
I think it's Lydia who sure to handle
you because I think they they should
handle all the males and isms in this
show I love him well he I think if he
had time he probably would this is not a
guest star type show which is in a way
it's important we do have one though in
our opening episode that is absolutely
hilarious okay and what is your age I am
ageless and it's delicious and in fact
for particularly just a night we're so
nervous is there funny you get nervous
because Rita's nervous are you serious
come on please like nervous tie your
present I have one you know what god I
have to memorize big sheets of dialogue
and stuff I'm 88 for pete's sake you
think that's easy I think you're in your
prime I think you're they think you're
right thank you are this has my Prime
has come very late but it's here with a
vengeance
my last question we celebrate Women's
Day in March every year and I would love
to know who is a woman that has really
championed you has mentored you elevated
you someone we know in the public eye is
there a name that well I think there's a
lady who thinks I'm just the bee's knees
and it's Michelle Obama I have a picture
with her because when I was doing West
Side Story she visited the set and it's
a snapshot actually and Steven Spielberg
brilliant up and she wrote on it you are
my hero how do you feel I peed my pants
excuse me my knickers that's the
reaction I would expect
oh my are you texting damn near died are
you are you friendly with her I'm
friendly with her but we don't text
because she's got
insane life and I really I honestly feel
that I don't want to intrude if I want
to say something there I'm not sure I
shy about doing it but I haven't wanted
that badly to say something to her so I
want to save that for when I really
really need to say something to her
[Music]